>> THEY'RE SEARCHING FOR ANSWERS
AND ALSO MAYBE SEARCHING FOR THE
RIGHT QUESTIONS AND MESSAGES TO
BE ASKING THEMSELVES.
KATE BENNETT, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
>> VERY CANDID REMARKS.
>>> AFTER THE SUPREME COURT
OVERTURNED ROE VERSUS WADE THERE
ARE STILL MAJOR QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHETHER THE COURT IS GOING TO
TRY TO USE THE FRAMEWORK FOR
THAT DECISION TO REPEAL RIGHTS
BEYOND ABORTION LIKE MAYBE
SAME-SEX MARRIAGE.
SENATOR TED CRUZ BELIEVES THAT
THE SUPREME COURT WAS, QUOTE,
CLEARLY WRONG WHEN IT LEGALIZED
SAME-SEX MARRIAGE IN THE
LANDMARK RULING IN 2015.
>> LIKE ROE v. WADE THEY IGNORED
TWO CENTURIES OF OUR NATION'S
HISTORY.
MARRIAGE WAS ALWAYS AN ISSUE
THAT WAS LEFT TO THE STATES.
THE COURT SAID, NO, WE KNOW
BETTER THAN YOU GUYS DO AND NOW
EVERY STATE MUST SANCTION AND
PERMIT GAY MARRIAGE.
I THINK THAT DECISION WAS
CLEARLY WRONG WHEN IT WAS
DECIDED.
IT WAS THE COURT OVERREACHING.
>> JOINING US NOW IS CNN
POLITICAL COMMENTATOR MARGARET
HOOVER AND CNN SENIOR POLITICAL
ANALYST JOHN AVALON.
I KNOW BOTH OF YOU HAVE A LOT OF
THOUGHTS ON THIS.
>> I LOVE WAKING UP TO THE
LATEST ANANITY FROM TED CRUZ.
IF THE UNINITIATED ARE WATCHING
AND THINK THAT'S INTERESTING A
SENATOR FROM TEXAS MAYBE WE
SHOULD LOOK AT THIS.
LET'S BE REMINDED THAT TED CRUZ
IS PANDERING NOT JUST TO THE
BASE OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY BUT
TO THE WORST KIND OF BIGOTRY IN
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
THE TEXAS GOP HAS PASSED THIS
PLANK SAYING THAT GAY MARRIAGE
IS ABNORMAL.
YOU KNOW THAT CLARENCE THOMAS
HAS SAID IN THE SUPREME COURT
DECISION OVERTURNING ROE IN
DOBBS THAT WE SHOULD REEXAMINE
PREVIOUS PRECEDENTS.
OF COURSE, CLARENCE THOMAS
DIDN'T SUGGEST WE SHOULD
REEXAMINE LOVING V. VIRGINIA
WHICH ARGUES THAT MARRIAGE IS A
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT.
THE DECISION IS ABOUT
INTERRACIAL MARRIAGE WHICH
CLARENCE THOMAS BENEFITS FROM
THAT LAW AND THAT READING OF THE
CONSTITUTION.
SO ALL OF THIS IS CIRCULAR INN
ANITY AND PANDERING TO THE BIG
KNOTS.
>> IT'S NOT THAT TO THE EXTENT
THAT CRUISE IS DIG FIEG WHAT
CLARENCE THOMAS WROTE THAT THE
OTHER JUST SIS SAID WE ARE NOT
TALKING ABOUT THAT.
YOU HEARD HIM SAY HISTORICALLY
AS A MATTER OF TRADITION
MARRIAGE WAS LEFT UP TO THE
STATES.
I MEAN, HE JUST INVALIDATED BY
THAT LOGIC LOVING V. VIRGINIA
WHICH EVERYONE WILL SAY WE ARE
NOT TALKING ABOUT THAT.
>> ALITO SPECIFICALLY SAID IN
HIS RULING THIS DOESN'T RAISE
ANY QUESTIONS BEYOND ABORTION,
BUT CLARENCE THOMAS SPECIFICALLY
SAID IT DOES AND TED CRUZ IS NOW
SAYING, YEAH.
>> WHAT THIS IS ABOUT, RIGHT, IS
ON THE POLITICAL SIDE YOU ALWAYS
WANT TO START GATHERING MOMENTUM
POLITICALLY SO THAT THE COURT --
BECAUSE THE COURT HAS
TRADITIONALLY BEEN AFRAID OF
BEING AHEAD OF WHERE THE PUBLIC
OPINION IS ON ANY POLITICAL
ISSUE.
70% OF THE COUNTRY IS IN FAVOR
OF SAME-SEX MARRIAGE NOW.
55% OF REPUBLICANS AS OF 2021
WERE IN FAVOR OF SAME-SEX
MARRIAGE.
THE COUNTRY HAS GOTTEN MORE IN
FAVOR OF SAME-SEX MARRIAGE NOT
LESS BUT THE COUNTRY IS ALSO
MORE IN FAVOR OF CERTAIN
RESTRICTIONS AND PROTECTIONS OF
ABORTION AND THE COURT REVERSED
THAT.
>> RIGHT.
>> SO THE THING THAT CONCERNS
ME --
>> I'M SORRY.
>> NO, THAT'S FINE.
>> -- THE REPUBLICAN HERE IS,
YOU KNOW, YOU CAN'T BE NAIVE
ABOUT WHEN THEY'RE THREATENING
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS IF YOU
THOUGHT NOTHING WOULD EVER
HAPPEN TO ROE.
>> RIGHT NOW CONSERVATIVES ARE
SAYING, LOOK, WE HAVE THE COURT
DOESN'T MATTER WHAT PUBLIC
OPINION IS.
IF THERE IS A DISCONNECT BETWEEN
RULINGS AND THE VAST MAJORITY OF
PUBLIC OPINION, A SEA CHANGE
OVER THE LAST 20 YEARS, THAT IS
A POLITICAL PROBLEM FOR
REPUBLICANS, ALSO A LEGITIMACY
OF THE COURT PROBLEMS AND TED
CRUZ OF COURSE IS THROWING FUEL
ON THAT FIRE.
>> HOW DO CONSERVATIVE VOTERS
VIEW THIS?
DO THEY AGREE WITH TED CRUZ OR
ARE MORE ON THE SIDE THIS IS A
DECISION, WE'VE LIVED WITH THIS
AND THIS IS HOW IT SHOULD BE.
>> THEY JUST THREW OUT ROE AFTER
50 YEARS.
WHAT TED CRUZ IS DOING IS TRYING
TO STRENGTHEN HIS RIGHT FLANK
FOR FUTURE FANTASY PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN.
>> FANTASY?
>> YOU'RE RIGHT IT'S NOT THAT
FANTASTIC.
TED CRUZ IS DEFINITELY GOING TO
RUN FOR PRESIDENT.
>> I'M JUST SAYING CRUZ HAS A
FUNDAMENTAL LIKABILITY PROBLEM
AND THAT USUALLY MATTERS IN
THESE THINGS.
>> BUT YOUR QUESTION WAS ABOUT
CONSERVATIVE VOTE SNEERS WHAT DO
THEY THINK?
>> I THINK CONSERVATIVE VOTERS
THEY'RE DIFFERENT ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY BUT IN TEXAS IN
PARTICULAR THOSE SELF-IDENTIFIED
REPUBLICANS WHO TURN OUT FOR THE
CONVENTION IN TEXAS PROBABLY
LIKE IT.
>> DOES TED CRUZ SPEAK FOR
ANYONE BUT TED CRUZ IN THE
ARGUMENT?
>> HE SPEAKS FOR THE
SELF-IDENTIFIED REPUBLICANS
TURNING OUT IN PRIMARIES TRYING
TO THROW OUT EVERY REPUBLICAN
WHO VOTED TO IMPEACH TRUMP,
THERE'S THREE LEFT, IN TWO WEEKS
YOU HAVE PRIMARIES FOR
REPUBLICANS, TRYING TO TAKE OUT
THE LAST THREE WHO VOTED TO
IMPEACH TRUMP.
THE SELF-IDENTIFIED BASE OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY THEY'RE GOING
ALONG WITH THIS.
>> LOOK, JUST -- I KNOW THE NAME
CHENEY ISN'T POPULAR IN
REPUBLICAN CIRCLES ANYMORE, BUT
IF YOU ARE A RIGHT WING ACTIVIST
WHO SAYS I BELIEVE IN FREEDOM,